schlimme nachrichten diese woche leider
aus den usa es war schon lange
befürchtet worden jetzt ist es
eingetreten es wird tatsächlich ein
fünfter teil von rambo getriebe zu
schauen
ach ja und donald trump kündigt das uran
abkommen mit dem iran katastrophe weiter
läuft dafür noch seinen urin abkommen
mit russland aber das ist völlig andere
geschichte
es ist immer dasselbe alle sagen ihm
macht das nicht donald kündigen wir das
blödeste was du jetzt machen könntest
und natürlich macht das dann was fällt
ein zu dem man noch ein
[Musik]
immer wenn der den friedensnobelpreis
kriegt gibt kollege sein echo zurück das
wird natürlich ist irans mullah-regime
gefährlich keine frage die mullahs
bedrohen israel mission in syrien mit im
jemen aber zweck des abkommens war ja
nur das nukleare risiko zu verringern
über zehn jahre haben experten für
dieses abkommen geackert und dann reißt
eine alles wieder ein seinem
orangefarbenen arsch das kann doch nicht
wahr sein
schon vor seiner wahl hat trump nur über
den vertrag gelästert weil es ein obama
erfolg war ja
nix mehr baby nummer mister babys hat
sich aus gebiet krankheit jetzt einfach
mal behauptet der iran hätte
nachweislich gegen das abkommen
verstoßen was nach was ich nicht stimmt
das sind fake news entschuldigung
es sind fake news ja im schlimmsten fall
löst er jetzt im nahen osten eine
unkontrollierbare kettenreaktion aus in
diesem kopf würde man wirklich gerne
reinschauen können nein würde man ist
[Applaus]
niemand bilder
da
warum soll man da rein gucken das ist
ausschließlich die halterung für die
haare wenn sie mich fragen
und warum sollte sich nach dieser woche
noch irgendwer an verträge gebunden
fühlen trump zockt und hofft einfach
dass der iran am ende angebrochen kommt
aber was wenn nicht freunde sein
nationaler sicherheitsberater john
bolton will doch seit jahren einen krieg
mit iran
woher man das weiß er hat allen erzählt
es gibt nur eine lösung wir müssen das
regime austauschen und deshalb werden
wir noch vor 2019 zusammen in teheran
feiern ja krieg noch dieses jahr
überhaupt nicht meine damen und nochmal
so bedrohlich die mullahs sind alle
versuche im nahen osten irgendein regime
auszuwechseln endeten immer im totalen
desaster
israels ministerpräsident netanjahu die
hat neulich in einer großen
pressekonferenz der welt beweise
präsentiert und zwar beweise dass die
iraner aktenordner besitzen ein
billy-regal und es kommt noch dollar
dass ihre musik immer noch auf cd höher
[Applaus]
noch mal hier sind ihr nicht
zusammenfassung dieser
iran liegt extra groß geschrieben
natürlich damit trump es auch lesen kann
inzwischen haben die israelis übrigens
bestätigt dass das unterlagen aus der
zeit vor dem atom abkommen waren
was stimmt der iran finanziert immer
wieder terroristen und mit terror
unterstützer im bildschirm natürlich
nichts zu tun haben
es sei denn sie haben öl und können
tanzen
die saudis die marke ja ohnedies audi
ist hätte es zwar al qaida gar nicht
gegeben aber sie sind ja gleichzeitig
wahnsinnig gute kunden als der saudische
thronfolger neulich im weißen haus war
hat der us waffensysteme für kein witz
400 milliarden us dollar bestellt 400
milliarden einfach mal so trump hat sich
vor freude schier eingenässt million des
vereins chronik bei williams hat den
prinzen zum lachen gebracht und der
lacht sonst nur bei enthauptungen
verstehen sie er ist ja ein reformer
400 milliarden
verstehen sie schwamm macht gerade aus
dem nahen osten ein noch größeres
pulverfass und hat schon vorher dafür
gesorgt dass sein land an diesem fass
ordentlich verdient und wir europäer
sind muss man so sagen endgültig
blamiert freunde der präsident der
vereinigten staaten setzt sich eiskalt
über unsere wünsche hinweg dieser
schulhof schläger wir schalten live vor
die amerikanische botschaft in berlin zu
ulrich von heesen ullrich ist dass
gerade ein neuer tiefpunkt für unsere
beziehungen zu den usa
ja das kann man so sagen welche die
letzten tage waren die ultimative
demütigung makro und merkel haben
tagelang in washington gebettelt damit
trump im abkommen bleibt marco sogar mit
zunge nix hat es gebracht im us
fernsehen wird gerade richtig stimmung
gegen deutschland gemacht ihr echter
spot
ich habe hier sogar t shirts drucken
lassen jetzt workshops hatte
[Applaus]
dieser spot ist von einer
verbraucherorganisation die beschweren
sich über die diesel karten von vw
und die soll die fresse halten und die
scheiße kaufen genau wie ja ich habe es
so die schnauze voll krieg im nahen
osten ist das eine aber jetzt wird
benzin teurer
das geht gegen nicht persönlich ich bin
seit dienstag mit mehreren meiner carius
gar nicht wegen fahren und merkel macht
nichts
ja ja zum als neuer botschafter in
berlin direkt öl ins feuer gießt ist
kaum in tegel gelandet der mann da
twittert er im befehlston hier deutsche
firmen sollen im medien sofort ihre
geschäfte im iran beenden
also es ist so eine freche wenn ich
irgendwo eingeladen bin und komme da das
erste mal hin
dann kann ich den leuten jahr nicht zur
begrüßung auf den wohnzimmerteppich oder
wobei ist mir auch schon passiert
[Applaus]
das war eine wette
das war ne wette ok ich weiß wir mussten
den teppich wegschmeißen
und weißt du was wir europäer werden
gehorchen wir werden auch das wieder
runterschlucken kleine armselige
billiger sind
aber nicht mit mir ich ernähre mich ab
sofort ausschließlich von produkten die
wir aus dem iran importieren was
importieren wir dann aus dem iran
ja ist der haken das sind im
wesentlichen trockenfrüchte aprikosen
uns und sagen na ja
deutsche firmen werden wohl kaum für den
iran auf ihr us geschäft verzichten
ja warum nicht die eu muss endlich
erwachsen lassen
zur not schließen wir uns der
volksrepublik china an
ist mir egal wichtig ist dass wir
zusammenhalten da muss man auch mal
opfer bringen egal was es kostet und
jetzt hab ich gemacht ich gehe zu
mcdonald's sind ja amerika gehen
ok